the other topic that came up and he took
just a couple of questions after he
provided some prepared remarks
he was asked about whether to what
extent
having fans present for some games no
fans present for other games due to the
pandemic and it seems like more and more
teams won't have fans present he was
asked a simple question of whether or
not it's a competitive advantage for
some of those stadiums to have fans in
them
he said we do not believe its
competitive advantage we discussed it
very early on with our competition
committee and with our clubs we do not
see that we obviously have varying
capacities across the league and from
our standpoint we want to invite our
fans if we can do it safely and we can
do it with the full support of local
officials we think our fans want to come
to the stadium um
you know
how is that possible just let me say
this is this like spin just to say like
to squash the subject like are they
spinning it just to be like yeah there's
no competitive advantage and act like
it's not even there or
does he truly believe that like i mean
come on we've already heard coaches say
there's a there's a there's a
competition issue there
we all have eyes and we all have ears
and we all have brains i mean
look
i i'm i'm choosing my words here
carefully and i just wonder i wonder if
someone would have even tried to say
that with a straight face five years ago
right or have we gotten to a point in
our society where you just say whatever
you want to say
just say whatever you want to say as
long as it meshes with your interests or
because you just don't feel like
conceding the point even if the point
needs to be conceded you know it used to
be
more than five years ago i think i'm
gonna use five years ago as the dividing
line it used to be people were concerned
about their credibility it used to be
that people would admit something that
they had to admit because if you don't
then no one's ever going to believe
anything you say that's the problem here
to the extent that the commissioner
wants people to believe him on other
things there are certain things you have
to concede
you must concede there's a competitive
advantage if you have fans in your
stands
or if you don't now i think he was
trying to make a more nuanced point but
the problem is when you come out of the
gate saying
it's not a competitive advantage the
nuanced point gets lost and one of his
nuanced points is well you know some
teams have i have you know more fans
they've got a greater capacity it's
louder so if we're going to go down this
path of competitive advantage then maybe
all stadiums should be limited in size
maybe the cowboys should be allowed to
have a hundred thousand maybe the
seahawks shouldn't be allowed to design
their stadium in a way to amplify the
sound you know there's a lot of stuff
that happens to enhance the home field
advantage but still there is a home
field advantage there is there is a
benefit there is a competitive edge and
if some teams have no fans and other
teams do yes it makes a difference and i
don't know why and this gets back to
last week
when we were talking about mike zimmer's
comments and sean mcdermott's comments
the vikings and bill's coach
respectively and and and i said why
didn't the nfl just come out and say
we're we're chasing the money here and
actually the real point is they're
catering to those fans that desperately
want to go to the games just admit that
we've got fans who want to come to our
games and we're not going to close the
door on them
in a place where they're allowed to come
to the games just because in another
community they're not allowed to come to
the games
i i i don't get it i mean it is what it
is i don't understand you're right why
can't we just call it for what it is
this year yeah some teams are going to
have a little advantage
i mean all right it's not a normal year
everybody knows that everybody
like everybody in the world knows like
you're not gonna hurt anybody's feelings
if he came out and went yep i'm you know
it's i'm sorry you know we're trying to
do the best for our league here there's
a lot of moving parts and yeah
unfortunately because the way the the
the pandemic has you know run its course
and the states are involved that some
teams are going to have a little
advantage this year i don't think like
people would be like oh my gosh
he admitted it
teams are going to have an advantage i'm
not going to watch football this year
this is bullcrap one team's going to
have 20 000 the other one's not it's not
fair i'm not watching i don't even
understand like
that it's and and to your point it goes
on a lot in our society right now never
be wrong just stay say something say
something and like kind of let some
people figure it out and then other
people just go wherever they want with
it but who's going to believe this
nobody i mean you know for a lot of the
other things we hear that aren't true in
our society there's a group of people
that is going to believe it no matter
what where is the base
that roger goodell is catering to by
saying
who who who's gonna other than jerry
jones right and maybe that's the answer
maybe again to get back to the point we
made last week about the anthem maybe
they need to remove roger goodell's name
from the football and put jerry jones
name on it because maybe that's why he
said it so jerry jones can cram as many
bodies as he possibly can into
the uh stadium there and in texas you're
allowed to have up to 50 capacity and
jerry jones suggested last week they're
going to be south of that but still they
may have more fans than anyone else and
is it a competitive advantage yes it is
why not just say chris this isn't going
to be a perfect year we understand that
we all get that exactly there are
challenges we'd rather have 256
imperfect games than zero perfect games
and and and people would accept no one's
going to kill him for that we get it we
want football even if there are going to
be some things that aren't
fair that's what might rico told us last
week and he did it much more eloquently
than i ever could this isn't going to be
a fair season period yeah let's accept
it and let's move on and let's not let's
not say things that are completely
you know over the top uh where folks are
just going to roll their eyes and say
what what in the world is he even trying
to sell right okay another thing that
roger goodell said is that as it relates
to the success they're having with covet
19 we're not patting ourselves on the
back yet which is smart and that's one
thing i hear all the time anytime the
nfl does do a little mini victory lap
with the numbers and they do kind of pat
themselves on the back a little bit hey
ho ho let's not get carried away here
because we're going to get people
complacent beyond the ever-present
concern for a jinx we're going to get
guys complacent if we act like
everything's fine and it's no big deal
so it's smart for a voice like roger
goodell's to be used to say to everyone
hang on we still got a long way to go
here we have yet to beat this we're just
trying to co-exist with it
yeah i don't get cocky with this thing
we know yes protocols have been put in
the right spot i mean everything looks
like it's going in the right direction
but we know i mean we see evidence
things can change in a heartbeat you
know look at colleges opening up other
hot spots we've seen around the country
when people gather or whatever else you
know there could be issues there so yeah
you certainly this is not the type of
thing you could start to feel good about
and puff out your chest and be like yeah
we're dominating cover 19 for a month
now all right well it's a long fight so
we just got to uh you know stay on our
what is it p's and q's there and make
sure we stay on top of our game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports